Laissez-le tranquille !
Barrez-vous !
Salut à tous, c’est Ludo
de la chaîne YouTube Le Tatou !
Aujourd’hui, je suis avec Brut
et on va parler d’une pratique
qui divise les campagnes françaises.
D’un côté, il y a ceux
qui soutiennent une tradition ancestrale.
De l’autre, des défenseurs de l’environnement
qui se battent pour l’abolir.
La chasse à courre propre,
ça n’existe pas.
Il y a tout le temps de la violence,
tout le temps de la cruauté,
c’est la finalité de la chasse à courre.
On ne peut pas dire que ce soit
une belle chasse, c’est pas vrai.
Et au milieu de ça, il y a des riverains
qui veulent juste être tranquilles chez eux.
Ici, on a des enfants,
on a des mamans, on a des familles...
Et on a peur !
C’est vrai qu’on a peur.
Elle déchaîne les passions
et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Avec Brut,
je vais vous parler de la chasse à courre.
Aujourd’hui,
les parties de chasses à courre
finissent souvent en confrontations
entre les militants pro et anti-chasse.
Ils se filment mutuellement, se provoquent
et parfois même, ils en viennent aux mains.
Tu déconnes ?
Oh, il a un taser !
Dehors !
Un taser ?!
Un taser mais...
Toi, la pétasse, dehors !
Eh ! EH !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais, là ?!
Eh monsieur, je suis calme.
Calmez-vous !
Dehors !
Qu'est-ce que vous faites, là ?
Vous me prenez à la gorge ?!
DEHORS !
Mais avant de vous raconter tout ça,
il faudrait peut-être que je vous explique :
c’est quoi la chasse à courre ?
La chasse à courre, d’ailleurs c’est plutôt
la chasse "à courre, à cor et à cri" ou la vénerie,
consiste à chasser un animal sauvage
uniquement avec une meute de chiens.
Ce sont les chiens qui poursuivent le gibier,
encadrés par un équipage qui est à cheval
ou même à pied
qu’on appelle les veneurs.
Après plusieurs heures de poursuite,
le gibier, épuisé, est "servi",
c’est-à-dire tué
par l’un des veneurs avec une lance.
L’animal tué n’est pas mangé par les chasseurs
mais il est servi aux chiens
lors d’une cérémonie
que les veneurs appellent : la curée.
En vénerie, on peut chasser la moitié de l’année
des espèces bien spécifiques :
le cerf, le chevreuil, le sanglier, le renard, le lièvre et le lapin.
Mais bon, le plus simple,
c’est qu’on regarde comment ça se passe.
Là, on cherche la trace d’un cerf,
ce qu’on appelle
plus communément le "vol-ce-l’est".
Le "vol-ce-l’est" donc, c’est l’empreinte de l’animal,
que le cerf laisse sur le terrain.
Le chien a senti, il s'est mis à tirer fort.
Et en fait, vous avez le pied
de l'animal, ici, là, qui monte.
Donc le rôle essentiel de ce matin,
c’est de pouvoir remettre un animal
à un endroit bien défini
pour pouvoir l’attaquer
avec ses congénères tout à l’heure.
Nord-Ouest, Nord-Ouest !
On va partir à cheval de la champignonnière,
avec les chiens et donc on va descendre
et on va passer par le village, comme d’habitude.
Et puis après, on descendra jusqu’en forêt
et on ira à la brisée à cheval avec les chiens.
Bon, lors de cette chasse,
aucune bête n’a été prise.
Et d’après les veneurs, ils n’arrivent réellement
à prendre le gibier qu’une fois sur 4.
Pour la curée, c’est un peu plus compliqué
de vous montrer des images
parce qu’en général, les caméras
ne sont pas les bienvenues lors de cette cérémonie.
On l'a, vous fatiguez pas.
C'est vous qui nous fatiguez,
là, en l'occurrence.
*Applaudissements*
Montrez-nous une curée alors !
- Mais je ne vous invite pas chez moi !
Vous avez rien à faire chez moi.
- Ah bah alors, il faut savoir !
Il y a rien à cacher, il y a pas de souci.
- Vous êtes pas si fiers de ce que vous faites
si vous cachez à chaque fois les mises à mort.
C'est pas hyper cohérent.
- La mise à mort, va dans un abattoir. Va ailleurs.
La mise à mort...
Elle a jamais été belle, la mise à mort.
La mise à mort, c'est un acte moche.
- Oui, mais là, vous en faites un jeu.
Pourquoi vous faites la fête
autour de ça, alors ?
Qualifiée de cruelle et barbare par ses détracteurs,
la chasse à courre
est défendue par ses sympathisants.
Je comprends tout à fait
qu’il y ait des gens qui considèrent
que de chasser un animal
pendant des heures soit cruel.
Mais en fait, ce sont des gens qui ne connaissent pas.
Parce que ce qu’on fait faire à l’animal,
ce n’est pas d’une cruauté extraordinaire.
L'animal est dans son élément.
Deuxième point, il court devant les chiens.
Et cette course, finalement, elle est une course qui fait...
quoi, disons... entre 2 et 4 heures
et qui est pas très différente de ce que fait
un marathonien quand il fait 40 kilomètres en courant.
Ce que j’apprécie, c’est...
Je suis très tournée vers les animaux,
donc j’aime beaucoup mon cheval
et puis les chiens,
le travail des chiens, c’est extraordinaire à voir.
Bien sûr, on défend la chasse !
Surtout la vénerie !
C’est important. Ça fait partie de la France !
Un cerf, il mérite une belle chasse,
qu’il puisse se défendre,
parce que qu’il n’est pas pris
à chaque fois, loin de là.
Les détracteurs parlent parfois
d’une certaine souffrance de l’animal ?
Tout le monde souffre.
Les humains souffrent aussi.
*Rires*
- Les poules dans les abattoirs.
En ce moment,
moi je suis en train de vous parler, je souffre.
Ça fait partie de la vie, ça !
*Rires*
Mais voilà, il y en a qui ne sont
pas vraiment d’accord avec ça.
Et c’est ce qu’on va voir avec Jimmy,
qui, avec d’autres militants anti-chasse,
s’organisent pour empêcher cette pratique.
Donc là, c’est des veneurs
Ah non !
ou des gens qui sont proches des veneurs,
qui vont nous suivre en forêt.
Officiellement, c’est pour empêcher
qu’on fasse des bêtises,
en tout cas, c’est leur version,
mais ils sont surtout là
pour nous empêcher de filmer
et éventuellement nous agresser
si on passe devant la chasse, par exemple
ou si on a des images compromettantes.
Alors déjà, c’est eux qui viennent en forêt
pour suivre la chasse,
n’inversons pas les rôles.
Ensuite, nous, si on est là, c’est pour empêcher
qu’ils volent les chiens comme ils le font souvent,
qu’ils agressent les veneurs,
on a un ami qui a encore une minerve
15 jours après son agression par Jimmy et ses copains.
Attention, il y a des oreilles qui traînent !
- Tu ferais mieux de t'en méfier, ouais.
C'est bon ? Alors ?
- C'est bon. Ils sont partis chasser là-bas.
- Okay.
- En gros, ils sont partis comme ça.
- D'acc.
Il y a un cavalier qui est passé par là.
Peut-être qu’on se rapproche, en fait,
je sais pas où il est passé ensuite.
Les consignes qu’on m’a données aujourd’hui,
c’est de vous dire que c’est une propriété privée.
C’est interdit d’entrer, pour vous.
- Vous êtes dans un rôle de prévention ou de police ?
- Moi ? La police de la chasse.
- La police, d’accord, donc vous êtes assermenté ?
- Oui, tout à fait.
- Ok. Et je peux voir votre matricule ?
- Oui, bien sûr.
Il n’y a pas de matricule, là.
- Comment ?
- C’est un agrément, c’est pas une assermentation, ça.
Vous n’êtes pas assermenté. Voilà.
- Attendez.
- Non, non c’est bon.
Le monsieur te notifie
que c’est une propriété privée et tu t’en fous.
Ouais, ouais,
il a menti aussi tout à l'heure.
Tu t'en fous.
Non mais là, vous êtes dans un rôle de police
mais vous n'avez pas le droit normalement.
Jimmy !
Il a menti,
c'est pas marqué "propriété privée".
Alors moi je vous ai
prévenu que c'était interdit...
C'est bon, voilà !
Restez dans votre rôle de prévention.
On vous remercie. Belle journée !
*Chants*
Jimmy, c'est tout le temps comme ça ?
Là, non, ils font un peu dans le côté spectaculaire
parce qu’il y a les journalistes,
mais sinon, c’est beaucoup plus agressif.
*Sifflotements*
Le fait d’avoir
une pression récurrente sur les équipages,
ça les oblige à faire plus attention à leurs pratiques.
Ça passe aussi l’envie à certains d’aller chasser,
c’est une pratique qui coûte très cher.
Donc, les gens
n’ont plus forcément envie d’autant investir,
d’autant aller chasser sachant qu’ils passeront
une mauvaise journée du fait de notre présence.
Il y a toujours eu des gens qui n’aimaient pas la chasse.
Ça, on l’entend bien !
"J’aime pas la chasse, j’aime pas la chasse."
Mais aujourd’hui, on a des gens qui disent :
"Moi, j’aime pas la chasse et je ne veux pas que tu chasses."
"Moi, j’aime pas la viande
et je ne veux pas que tu en manges."
"Moi, j’aime bien les petits veaux
et je ne veux pas qu’on en élève pour les tuer."
"Moi, j’aime bien les taureaux
et je ne veux pas qu’on fasse de la corrida."
C’est une forme d’intolérance.
Est-ce que ça m’inquiète ? Oui.
Oui, parce que c’est clivant.
Voilà, on est en train de fracturer fortement la société.
Moi, je suis dans mon droit, vous vous ne l’êtes pas.
- Vous êtes dans le droit de taper une militante ?
- Et vous venez nous emmerder. Hein ?
- Et de tenter de noyer des militantes ?
- Vous avez jamais tapé de militants ?
- Tu as une preuve de ce que tu dis ?
Est-ce que je suis impliqué dans une seule,
dans une seule, dans une seule... procédure ?
- On va se revoir au tribunal bientôt.
- Ce sera avec plaisir mais tu ne vas pas être déçu.
Vous l’aurez compris,
c’est hyper tendu entre pro et anti-chasse
et d’ailleurs,
quand les caméras des journalistes ne sont pas là,
c'est un peu plus violent que ce qu’on a pu voir.
Oh mais eh ! Mais ça va pas non ?!
Eh !
Vous nous agressez, a...
Vous dégagez !
- Vous ne touchez pas aux femmes !
- Mais vous ne connaissez pas la loi monsieur ?
Mais j'en ai rien à foutre !
Mais ta loi, tu sais ce que j'en fais ?!
Au-delà de ces deux camps qui s’opposent,
il y a des riverains qui aimeraient juste
que leur propriété privée soit respectée.
C’est le cas de Xavier, un professionnel du tourisme
qui loue des logements au cœur de la nature.
Barrez-vous !
Mais c'est affreux !
Nous ici, au quotidien, ce qu’il se passe,
c’est qu’on est envahis par la chasse à courre.
On a des clients qui viennent là
et des chiens qui déambulent absolument partout,
mais qui déambulent pour quoi ?
Eh bien, pour repérer le gibier, justement, à traquer.
En l’occurrence le cerf ou le sanglier.
On peut faire le planning des chasses,
on a le mardi chasse à tir, le mercredi chasse à courre,
le jeudi chasse à courre au chevreuil,
le vendredi chasse à courre au sanglier,
le samedi on a la chasse à courre au cerf,
le dimanche, on a la chasse dominicale…
Un climat assez particulier quand même.
Et si on regardait de plus près ce que dit la loi ?
Elle explique que :
"Nul n'a la faculté de chasser sur la propriété d'autrui
sans le consentement du propriétaire
ou de ses ayants droit."
Mais la loi autorise à achever
un animal mortellement blessé
car ce n’est pas considéré
comme un acte de chasse.
Mais depuis peu, un arrêté a mis fin à cette autorisation
si l’animal se trouve à proximité d’habitations,
de jardins privés, de zones commerciales...
En gros, on n’a plus le droit
de tuer un animal chez quelqu’un
mais apparemment, c’est compliqué de tout maîtriser.
Laissez-le tranquille !
Barrez-vous !
Mais c'est affreux !
Rappelez vos chiens !
On avait donc là 4 ou 5 chiens,
je sais pas, qui étaient sur la bête.
La bête qui hurlait, je vous laisse
imaginer la bande-son du truc quoi.
Et clairement, ils l’ont dépecé vivant.
Après, il a réussi à repartir
et aller un petit peu plus sur la gauche, là.
T’as le chien qui est venu
qui a commencé à lui choper la langue
et après, ils lui ont fait la dorsale,
ils ont mangé toute la dorsale.
Vous me rendez fou !
Rappelle tes chiens !
Rappelle...
tes chiens !
Tout de suite !
- Il faut vous calmer. D'accord ?
Ça ira mieux après, hein.
Tout de suite !
Rappelle tes chiens.
- Vous allez faire un...
Rappelle tes chiens. Rappelle tes chiens !
- On n'a pas fait les classes ensemble !
Hein, d'accord ?
Mais je veux pas être votre ami !
Bon ! Moi non plus !
Alors tu me tutoies pas !
Quand on fait des courriers recommandés,
un, deux, trois, quatre.
Quand on contacte les équipages,
quand on contacte la police, la gendarmerie,
la police de la chasse
et il y a rien qui change ?
Nous, la volonté, elle est là,
clairement, on veut pas arrêter la chasse,
on n’arrêtera jamais la chasse.
On demande juste, simplement,
à respirer tranquillement, à être en sécurité chez nous,
à pouvoir exercer notre activité, sereinement.
C’est ça qu’on demande. Tout simplement.
En Angleterre et au Pays de Galles,
la chasse à courre a été interdite
avec le "Hunting act" au début des années 2000.
Mais elle est encore légale en France
et défendue par certains.
Pour d’autres, il est temps que cette pratique cesse.
Alors tradition noble ou pratique barbare ?
À vous de vous faire votre propre avis.
Moi, j’ai déjà le mien.